تبع الان هذه الصور التي تاتينا من
العاصمتين العراقيه بغداد وكذلك الاردنيه
عمان لمسيرات في هذه الجمعه دعما ل قطاع
غزه وتنديدا بالحرب
الاسرائيليه على القطاع وعلى الفلسطينيين
معنا من عمان مراسل الجزيره كما نشاهده في
هذه الصوره حسان الشوبكي ومعه نتابع هذه
المسيره ايضا في جمعه اخرى في الع
[موسيقى]
نعم عبد القادر يعني بعد اليوم الخامس بعد
المئه هنالك احتجاجات اردنيه متواصله في
شمال المملكه وفي جنوبها وايضا في كل
المناطق هنا في العاصمه عمان خرج
المتظاهرون يطالبون بالوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار في
غزه ويطالبون بوقف العدوان عليها كما انهم
ينددون نددوا بالموقف المصري الذي قالوا
هنا انه يحاصر غزه وطالبوا بفتح معبر رفح
بالاضافه الى ذلك هنالك مطالبات بادخال
المساعدات الطبيه والغذائيه الى قطاع
غزه يقول المتظاهرون ان كل الجهد العربي
والاسلامي وكل الجهود الدبلوماسيه التي
تحاول ان تحدث شيئا جديدا لم تستطع حتى
اللحظه ان توقف هذه الحرب التي تشن
ضد المدنيين العزل في قطاع غزه وكذلك
وكذلك في الضفه الغربيه المحتله وهنالك
مطالبات ايضا بان
تصل الجهود السياسيه الى الضغط على
الولايات المتحده التي اعتبر المتظاهرون
هنا انها منحازه بالكامل الى اسرائيل
وانها لم لم لم تقدم حتى اللحظه ما يساعد
في وقف هذه
الحرب الجماهير الاردنيه التي خرجت منذ
ثلاثه اشهر ونصف اليوم بعد مرور
1055 ايام على هذا العدوان على غزه
العنوان الذي خرجوا فيه انها مقاومه وصمود
تضحيه واباء
ويحيون الشعب الصابر والصامد في غزه ويقول
المتظاهرون الاردنيون سواء في شمال
المملكه في محافظات الشمال التي خرجوا
فيها او في الجنوب جنوب البلاد وكذلك في
العاصمه عمان ان المقاومه هي السبيل
الاوحد لتحرير فلسطين وان كل المحاولات
لذهاب
ل
ت رفعوا صور الناطق العسكري باسم كتائب عز
الدين القسام ابو عبيده وكذلك رفعوا صور ل
يعني القاده الفلسطينيين المقاومين
والعنوان الابرز في الشعارات لبيك يا غزه
وان فلسطين ستنتصر وان امريكا هي را
العدوان عبد
القادر الاحتجاجات لا تتوقف يعني هي ليست
فقط بعد صلاه الجمعه في يوم الجمعه هي
ايضا على مدار الايام باشكال مختلفه
الشارع الاردني غاضب منما يحدث في غزه
ويطالب بان تنتهي هذه الاباده الجماعيه
التي تقودها اسرائيل والولايات المتحده ضد
المدنيين العزل في فلسطين